[Music]
you
holy crap everybody we got to freak out
about Episode five so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
we're almost done with the season so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there were so many bombs atomic bombs
dropped in this episode and Gilley's was
probably my favorite so list of top 10
WTF and easter eggs from the books there
were all kinds of references going back
to season 1 especially when John Beck
Gendry for the first time but let's
start at the top of the episode
Daenerys sentencing randyll Tarly and
Dickon to death so you have to feel bad
for Dickon but now you understand why
they had so many of those Jaime jokes
they want you to remember who he is and
why he's important they wanted you to
sympathize with them for a little bit I
feel like it kind of didn't work like a
lot of people are like maybe he's the
one that saved Jaime that probably would
have made people sympathize with them
more but that wound up being broad you
can't die until I get what's owed me
only I can kill you but I really love
the way they shot that scene though
where she walks into the bottom of the
frame just towers over everyone just to
show you visually with the camera how
much power she has if the giant dragon
behind her didn't do the trick
so many great Tyrion moments here
they're laying little bombs for each of
the storyline like Littlefinger left a
little bomb for Arya to find Gilly
dropped a big rhaegar targaryen Lyanna
stark bomb so this is the writers
dropping a Tyrion Daenerys bomb like she
won't be the mad Queen as long as she
has someone really good to counsel her
oh don't worry I'm not going to chop
their heads off if they just get
incinerated to ash right before everyone
there were a couple chuckles to be had
with the way that drogon screamed making
everyone immediately bend the knee but
you have to know that randyll Tarly is a
proud man and I love the way he went out
like a boss he lets Daenerys know
exactly what he thinks of her Tyrion in
the Dothraki so I'll understand if you
kind of sympathize with his character
because he was a great battle commander
but it's almost like they wanted there
to be no out for that situation like he
was never going to do what daenerys
wanted so she would have seemed weak had
she not burned them alive in by the end
of the episode Samwell still doesn't
know that they're dead the maester say
that they never told them and Samwell
never acknowledges it is there riding
away from the Citadel but number nine up
at Winter
fell we finally see that scene from the
trailer where brand wars all the Ravens
- find out where the army of the Dead is
in the night King looks like he's able
to break brand's control them so I would
say they're relatively evenly matched in
terms of power levels so it'll be
interesting to see if they have some
sort of psychic battle before the end of
the season because they're mostly
concerned with physical battles right
now especially with Jon Snow's party
that just made it north of the wall but
I love the way they follow up in the
Citadel you kind of know the direction
this was headed earlier in the season
where the maesters are meant to be this
really learned but very stuffy old stuck
in their ways organization and I know a
lot of people have conspiracies about
their plot to get rid of magic in the
world but that all just seems like way
too much story for the show to actually
handle so this is mostly just about
Samwell being really upset they're not
actually going to do something about
this but if you caught it there was some
really quick references from some of the
other maesters where they're talking
about the drowned God in other
prophecies things to mind what is Lucis
the charlatan is able to descend from
the shadows of the photos they forget
the profit models he promised that the
drowned God would rise up and destroy it
on the Conqueror they referenced Jenny
of old stones claiming to be descended
from the children of the forest in the
books she was married to a prince duncan
Targaryen she got a prophecy from a
witch in the woods that was another
version of the prince who was promised
so it's like them saying the maesters
got a version of the prophecy of the
prince who was promised it was kind of
true in a previous time but they didn't
listen so the cycle perpetuated so that
might have something to do with them
breaking the wheel this time breaking
the cycle of Ice and Fire but they
really just want you to hate these old
masters like yeah there's a prophecy
that is probably true you got it a long
time ago you didn't believe then meaning
that we have to deal with it again today
but it's another way for them to
continue to invoke the idea of the
prophecy of the prince who was promised
Jon Snow Daenerys Targaryen and
everything that people are talking about
the last couple of episodes
lots of stubborn people in the episode
even though Daenerys seems to listen to
Jon Snow like just like the maesters are
very stuck in their ways Daenerys seems
very stuck in the way that she's going
to deal with people
so you see Tyrion just sitting there oh
she didn't have any other choice like
he's trying to rationalize it and it
said burning people alive
embarrasses like oh yeah we used to do
that at the red keep I used to offer up
people to the Mad King I tried to
justify it in my mind say that this
isn't my fault that this is happening so
there are a couple things I'll try to
address through the course of the video
and one is the way they're trying to
hype up arya versus Sansa which i think
is a misdirect totally not going
anywhere and the other is Daenerys mad
queen also don't think that that's
actually going to lead to anything I
think they just don't have a whole lot
going on within each of these camps
outside of the main plot and they want
to add all this extra drama to make it
feel like it's justified spending all
these extra scenes at Winterfell when
really there's nothing happening at
Winterfell besides brand having visions
of the night King like right now
Daenerys is just sitting around waiting
for Jon Snow to get back with the white
they went to get for Cersei so that
everybody would come together during the
armistice but number 7 smuggler as
always Davos smuggles Tyrion into King's
Landing
these were probably some of the best
scenes in the episode in all of season 7
so far just because they're big payoffs
but Tyrians line where he's like last
time I was here I killed my father with
a crossbow and then finally Davos
remembers his son Mattos he hasn't
mentioned him this whole time last time
I was here you killed my son with
wildfire but that Tyrion Jaime seen next
to the Jon Snow drogon scene is my
favorite of the season so far
just big mythology payoff for Jon Snow
meeting drogon but it's a big character
payoff for Tyrion and Jaime together the
dialogue was better the pathos antarians
voice you start to get the idea that
Jaime's coming around but everybody's
worried about how sir she's going to
react to this she doesn't believe in the
army of the Dead Daenerys has an idea
she wants an armistice so I love the
follow-up to that to the idea that sir
she knew about all this was happening
because of her little bird so I'll
follow up with that in a second but we
have to talk about the gander uber Union
so number 6
Davos defines Gendry with a shaved head
oh the Lannister soldiers they don't
recognise me
I didn't think that I'd find you I
thought that you'd still be rowing so
was nice of them to reference the fandom
like all the memes about Gendry rowing
so that is the writer sort of winking at
you from behind the camera but before
Davos can even get a word in edgewise
kendrys like bam I'm ready to go oh no I
don't have a sword I have something even
better and we
so - I entrust like Roberts so this
isn't exactly like Roberts but it's made
to look as close as possible like it's
meant to invoke that imagery especially
once he meets up with John snow the
whole scene with Davos trying to
convince the gold cloaks to go away was
great
but I love the way the Tyrian comes
slowly walking down and it's just a way
for them to show you how Gendry can move
with the warhammer like he just brains
them on the spot so that's why when they
get to the Jon Snow meeting he's like oh
yeah he can handle himself don't worry
but number five the big Searcy bomb so
obviously she knew about the meeting the
whole time and let it happen
don't you ever betray me again in
reveals another big plot bomb dropped
that she's pregnant with another child
with Jamie he seems genuinely happy but
now you're like oh wait a minute does
this mean he's not going anywhere I
think it's another reason for him to not
leave and I'm fascinated to see it is
actually wise up happening in the books
because by this time in the story jamie
has long since left Circe's company they
haven't had sex in a long long time so I
feel like the whole purpose of this baby
is just to blow up by the end of the
season and make Cersei go even crazier
like it seems like she wants to meet
with Daenerys she's all about the
armistice so there's hope that they can
come together to fight the army of the
Dead but just think of how she'd react
and lash out if something were to happen
to that baby
even if Daenerys had nothing to do with
then she would just go off the rails
it's just something that's ready to blow
up in everyone's faces like the Gilly
bomb that was dropped so number four
Davos introduces Gendry to Jon Snow so
many great references to season one I
met your father he's talking about the
time when Ned Stark came looking into
John Aaron's business to find out about
Robert's bastards I Met Your father when
he came to Winterfell they acknowledge
the great things that they did together
during Robert's rebellion and Gendry
just seems really pumped up about going
to fight the army of the dead he's like
I can't sit this war out I have to do
something about this it almost feels
like a little bit of band service
because there's been so many times that
they've referenced moments from Robert's
rebellion or big things like they keep
talking about Rhaegar keep hinting it R
+ L equals J they keep referencing Aegon
the conquerer so this is just one of
those big payoff moments like what was
it like when Ned Stark and Robert
Baratheon fought together as young men
during the war
we'll get to see a version of that in
the next episode I love that Tyrion
scene with Jorah where he gives him the
coin that was from back in season 5 that
was a long time ago but really we got to
talk about the big ghillie bomb so
number three Gillies a human wiki four
facts and just starts reading up things
how many windows in the great Sept or
there none now oh yeah you know you're
right there's this Meister he recorded
everything it turns out he recorded this
uh no meant between someone called
Rhaegar in someone else down in Dorne
while he was also getting him married to
someone else so this is about as obvious
as they can be as a way to tell you that
Jon Snow is not a bastard which you
probably got a sense for when Miss and I
was asking them what is a bastard I have
no concept of that where I'm from and
Jon says it's because my mother and
father were not married so this is one
their confirmation that R plus L equals
J but also that they were married when
it happened
meaning that Jon Snow now has the most
legitimate claim to the Iron Throne
meaning did that plot bomb could blow up
in anyone's face whenever they want but
I don't think that he's going to find
out this season and I don't think the
Daenerys is either Samwell didn't even
sound like he was listening to Gilly
when she said that
so Gilly might be the one to blurt that
out but I still think that bran is going
to be the one to tell him about his
parents so you have a couple different
characters now that together have the
information that proved that Jon Snow
now has the strongest claim to the
throne but if you're wondering why his
claim is stronger than Daenerys is
because she's his aunt it's because of
primogeniture so it means that the crown
prince who had the strongest claimed as
a throne previously Rhaegar when he dies
or he died his entire estate meaning all
of his titles and his claim to the
throne passed directly to his oldest
living male heir jumping over any other
family members
so just because Daenerys was the brother
of the next king of Westeros it means
that the succession passes her over in
favor of John so again we just had to
reiterate the Jon Snow does not care
about being king he does not want the
Iron Throne so I don't think it's going
to wind up being a very big thing but it
is a very huge confirmation so we can
freak out about it in the comments but
as for him meeting drogon for the first
time obviously you see that moment
recognition in drogon like he sniffs him
he can sense that he's a Targaryen is a
really convenient way to show you how
they're acknowledging John snows lineage
and sets up future connections with the
Dragons meaning that yes I totally think
that Jon Snow will write a dragon before
season 8 is over but I do not think that
it's going to happen this season I think
this season is all about moving the
chess pieces around and explaining why
that's necessary so you learn about jon
snow's heritage to inform why it's
important that he be connected to
Daenerys so that they can fight the war
for the dawn but I think they're leaving
some of that big payoff for season 8
like Jon Snow riding a dragon feels like
one of the biggest things the show could
do they're definitely going to save that
for the final season in what dragon
would he ride what about the one that's
named after his father
regal so you can let me know in the
comments Jon Snow rides a dragon which
one does he ride first does he ride
drill GaN with the nearest or does he
ride rague all by himself but number two
obviously they dropped that big Arya
bomb Littlefinger proves that he's not
completely incompetent he uses Arya
skills against her to try and create
some more chaos inside Winterfell
maybe to stall for time you wonder what
his game is he wants Sansa so that he
can get to the Iron Throne
she needs control of Winterfell so if
Arya is fighting with her maybe that
would just keeps onca busy for the time
being maybe that's his only endgame at
this point because he still needs Sansa
so he doesn't want Arya to kill her but
the way they're playing it up in that
promo for the next episode makes it
sound like Arya definitely wants to kill
Sansa but again I don't think that's
going anywhere I think it's just hyping
up drama
where drama doesn't exist in they'll
both turn against Littlefinger quickly
after that once they find out what he's
been doing
he even add to that that she was forged
to write that letter during season 1 by
Cersei in everyone else so it's not
something that she believes she was just
forced to write it and then that was the
end of it she probably doesn't even
remember until Arya confronts her with
it so number one of course the last big
payoff Jon Snow's party arrives at East
Watch and you have all these amazing
reunions this is also one of my favorite
scenes of the episode where they turn up
tormund is hilarious as always which
Queen is is that you want the help of
the one with the dragons are the one
that has sex with her brother then
Gendry recognized
the Brotherhood tormund remembers Joris
father he was chasing us down so they
just want to show you that everybody has
a reason to hate each other but then
they come to their senses the gate opens
and they walk into the wall of whiteness
so metaphorically into the mouth of
madness it's going to be fun so
obviously big action episode next week
there's only two episodes left I believe
both of the episodes are longer than an
hour so it's going to be amazing
leave all your requests for bonus videos
in the comments below but let me know
like what was your favorite moment which
reunion was your favorite there's a lot
of big payoffs and even though they are
speeding through stuff it was a solid
episode probably most surprised by the
Cersei baby just because you know that
she's not long for this world like she's
got to die at some point even if you
don't believe in the valonqar she's very
clearly being presented as the
antagonist for the season like of all
the bad people next to the night king
she's the worst so it's like oh my god
now she's pregnant so of course it's
going to end spectacularly bad for
everybody involved what'll happen next
is I'll post my trailer video in the
morning for episode 6 then I'll post new
Rick and Morty congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Stephen Stapleton
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here to
learn all about the children of the
forest and the White Walkers symbols
from last week's episode and you can
click here for my episode 4 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight